for people switching on to it do you  recommend they go from the standard  American diet directly onto the  carnivore diet or do you do a weaning  process or is it dependent on the person  yeah I can make an argument for why  weaning magnet makes sense but  particularly somebody's on a bunch of  medications and if you rapidly drop that  they may have some pretty severe  transition symptoms enough to where they  don't want to do it because they feel so  bad if somebody's already been on a low  carb or ketogenic style diet ahead of  time that they generally can just drop  right into it but somebody that's on  this high carb junk food based standard  of American diet then they may find just  reducing some of the sugar the grain  processed foods firstly maybe  transitioning low carbs increasing the  high quality nutrition steak and eggs  often makes it a little bit easier for  them to do